Hello everyone
and welcome back to EU People.
Today we have Jean-Éric Paquet with us.
The science supremo
of the European Commission.
Together we will see if Europe is
staying ahead in the innovation race.
Jean-Éric is also a jack of all trades.
You will find his finger prints
on many EU initiatives.
Then, we will try to confront
Jean-Éric with his own creation, Nao,
a little brainy robot.
So, whether you’re bats
about biotechnology
or nuts for nuclear physics,
strap in, the show is for you.
I am delighted
to welcome Jean-Éric Paquet,
the Chief of the Research and Innovation
Department at the European Commission.
Together with his team,
Jean-Éric helps researchers,
push the boundaries of knowledge.
Watch out, the man heads
a 77-billion-euro research program.
What does he do with all this money?
Let's find out with our guest.
Good morning Jean-Éric.
Romain, good morning.
So technically, are you a billionaire?
Well that’s a nice way of putting it,
I don’t think
I’ve ever looked at it like that.
I mean, it’s the biggest
research programme in the world,
77 billion euros, that’s Horizon 2020,
and in fact we are even more even
more ambitious for the next programme,
Horizon Europe will be 100 billion euros
if we are followed by finance ministers
and the European parliament.
So, yes, it’s a very very big programme,
one which allows Europe
to invest into technologies,
into new science, new knowledge,
into the future really,
and in fact the billionaires
for me are not commission officials,
its really the scientists
and the citizens
which benefit
from this quite amazing programme.
I found some amazing pictures of you
in your daily work
and we’re going to see some,
it seems it’s quite fun
to lead research in Europe,
can you tell us a bit more
about your daily life?
Well, uh,
I mean my day starts on my bike in fact,
I bike into the office in the morning,
which gives me I think a good sense
of how much more we need to do
in the urban context.
On pollution?
Pollution,
also the way our cities are organised,
we do a lot of research on that.
Then I spend my day,
I´m extraordinarily privileged,
because on the one hand I meet only
very remarkably intelligent
and creative and smart people,
I mean all scientists,
so I learn absolutely every day,
and that is I think quite
a privileged position,
to work and learn.
Then I of course also do quite
a lot of more institutional work,
and right now a lot of my daily work is
about negotiating the future programme,
the one I mentioned,
Horizon Europe, 100 billion euros.
So, I’m travelling across Europe to meet
ministers and administrations
and also those
which will do the programme
with us to prepare the ground.
Can we look at concrete examples
from the Horizon 2020?
So, I’ve read in your brochure
that the EU helped to discover
7 planets, is it true?
Yes, yes yes, it is true,
very true, it was last year.
That’s again, I mentioned
the European Research Council,
this flagship European institution,
this noble prize factory.
It was funded by the ERC,
the ERC is a very important ground
which allows research teams in all areas,
this was astrophysics,
to carry out their research.
It’s a researcher from Liege,
so here from Belgium
which I find also very nice,
he used a telescope which is partly
European called Trapiste,
and his project was called Speculoos
which I think is also quite attractive,
and he indeed discovered 7 exo-planets,
which are these planets
outside the solar system,
these are not the first ones discovered
but any new discovery adds
of course knowledge
and maybe the perspective
for life beyond the solar system.
I’ve read also
that the EU funded research
on the DNA of a plant
and it saved a 7-year-old boy?
Yeah, he was,
most of his skin was disappearing,
and this was, again, an example
of a particularly rare disease,
a genetic disease.
Here we crossed disciplinary knowledge
and disciplinary science
and indeed the research project allowed
to provide a solution
and this kid is recovering
which is absolutely amazing.
Also, is it true
that the EU is helping to find
a sustainable alternative to plastics?
We need to provide alternatives to it,
and indeed we have funded,
I mean I can show you here,
this for example is a small pot
for cosmetics, which is,
which used to be often in plastic,
this one has exactly the same qualities,
the same properties but it degrades
in nature in a few weeks’ time,
which is really very remarkable.
This is a company in a Member State
which was indeed funded under
one of our instruments, the concept,
the innovation was there
but what they didn’t have
was the capacity to scale it up,
to make it
a real industrial possibility.
They are there now, now of course they
need to become a commercial success,
that’s not up to us,
that’s up to the company,
but this is really very remarkable.
Here’s another,
it’s all completely plastic
but that’s another nice example
of the circular economy.
This is a coffee cup,
we are still in the morning
so I will have a sip of it,
and this cup is made of coffee.
Itself?
The cup itself is coffee,
compressed coffee residue-
-coffee waste?
Exactly, coffee residues
from expresso machines,
it is compressed into this very
nice looking small cup.
So, the tabs
that you have in your coffee machine
that you throw away
are recycled to make this?
They can be recycled.
Jean-Éric,
you are a real jack of all trades.
Before going into research,
you worked in the Secretariat-General
of the Commission.
Among other things, you are behind
the European Solidarity Corps.
At first it was Jean-Claude Juncker,
the President of the Commission,
who announced the creation
of a European Solidarity Corps
in his State
of the Union address in 2016.
The idea is to create
a European programme
that allows young Europeans
up to 30 years old
to participate in solidarity activities
in the member states
of the European Union.
It’s not an entirely new idea.
There have been European volunteers
for two decades now,
but the President's idea was really
to cover more sectors,
all Member States, maybe older people,
to really allow them to demonstrate
their concern
and their wish for solidarity.
The idea is to propose to 100.000
young Europeans from now to 2020
to spend a few months up
to one year in a member state,
often another member state,
to help in the social sector,
the health sector,
the humanitarian sector,
and also perhaps in the environmental
or ecology sector.
There is huge demand
for young Europeans.
You would have done it too.
I suggested to my sons to sign up,
I think they signed up.
I don’t think they were selected,
but they signed up.
Would I have done it if I were young?
I believe so, yes.
A lot of questions come up in Europe,
as you already know,
and we collected
some questions that we found online.
There are concerns, there are hopes.
I’d like to hear your thoughts.
The first one is
on the European social rights framework.
Bruno made this caustic comment:
“What does the European framework
for social rights bring?
Short answer: Nothing.”
Well, I have a somewhat longer answer.
This European framework
for social rights is, first of all,
about showing Europeans that Europe
is not only the internal market.
Europe is not just free economy,
sometimes highly criticized in public
discourse in many Member States.
For the President of the Commission,
for the European institutions,
the social dimensions and the questions
related to jobs in particular
are also at the heart
of the European project
and at the heart of the European values.
To be more specific,
I will give you two measures
that have been agreed upon
by all the institutions.
The first is a measure that establishes
a minimum wage in Europe.
This seems very natural for a member
state such as France or Belgium,
where minimal wages have existed
for a very long time.
This is not the case
for all Member States,
so there it serves as a reference point.
So now many Member States are looking
into establishing a minimum wage.
But what’s more important—I’m also
thinking in terms of future policy—
is the principle
of a universal minimum wage,
which was proposed in this framework,
allowing all European citizens
to live with dignity.
This is obviously
an extremely ambitious concept
which is not yet operational
and is currently being tested.
It is being experimented on in Belgium,
Finland and other Member States
where in effect we are testing
the implementation of a minimum income.
I have another comment from Rico,
he shares one of his dreams on Twitter
and I’ll read it to you.
I think you’ll like this one:
“Could we imagine a train line
that connects the Netherlands to Spain,
France to Hungary,
passing through the north of Italy,
Greece to Bulgaria,
Romania, Slovakia, Poland and Estonia?
A train whose name
would be ‘European Union’?"
That’s a beautiful dream,
which is partly a reality.
What our reader
is suggesting is almost a network.
It exists in part,
we have this European transport network,
this European mobility network
which exists today,
at least in European policies,
which was implemented
in 2013 and which has,
first of all,
an infrastructure component,
as trains do have to circulate on rails
and often the difficulty is
to connect the national networks.
So that is the European policy,
to construct infrastructures connecting
the national networks,
the big tunnels such as the Brenner
or the Lyon-Turin in France.
But it’s also about having
trains moving on these rails,
and in my opinion
that's the real challenge,
finding railroad operators
offering these services.
The creation of a rail network
in Europe would make that happen.
There are obviously existing services.
Perhaps we have this image
of the Orient Express
or these large night trains
which are a collective European fantasy,
and which I believe
are behind this question.
And it’s obviously the operators
who first have to propose this to us,
it is not the Commission
that will implement railroad services,
but I admit that this is a dream
that I will gladly share.
And it’s also shared a little
by the European Parliament
and the Commission,
given that the Parliament proposed
to implement this Interrail,
this railroad pass, DiscoverEu,
to propose to each European citizen
that reaches the age of majority to have
this railroad pass for a few months,
allowing him to travel in Europe.
I don't know how old you are, Romain...
Too old.
-So maybe too old for the pass today
and maybe too young to have used
Interrail in your youth,
but it's true that in my generation,
we all had an Interrail pass
that we bought,
and we all travelled through Europe.
And you exchanged currencies?
It was amazing. I went down
to Greece from Strasbourg
when I was 15 or 16 years old.
We passed through Vienna,
and when we arrived
at the border with Slovenia,
then Croatia and after that Belgrade,
it was an extraordinary adventure.
At the time, we used to travel
to Yugoslavia without a visa.
It was truly remarkable.
German now, so we will have spoken
all the working languages
of the European Union.
I would like to try.
You are from Strasbourg, right?
My parents met in Paris.
In the early sixties.
But there is a long family history
associated with that.
My mother had a grandfather.
He served in the military in Strasbourg.
At the beginning of the 20th century.
Strasbourg was German then.
He was quite a Francophile.
My grandmother
on my father’s side was also German.
And then she became French.
So, there was already a bit of German
and a bit of French in both families.
And my parents met in Paris
at the beginning of the 60s,
which of course is totally romantic.
And then they had three children.
As children, we lived in Darmstadt,
Germany for a few years.
That's why we all speak a little German.
And then we grew up in Strasbourg.
You are a true child
of the Elysée Treaty!
Well, the Elysée Treaty is from 1962.
That is when my parents married.
My sister was born in ‘64,
and I a bit later.
Sometimes other Europeans have
some difficulty understanding
the significance of the special
German-French friendship.
Is that important to you?
I mean, Germany and France,
of course with other member states,
were there from the very beginning.
And the European project is a project
that comes from the Second World War.
And that is why,
with this family history,
the fact that I am now working
in European politics
here in Brussels is, of course,
something quite natural and normal.
But German-French,
that is an important dimension.
And it definitely still is today.
And that I can work
with Germans in German.
And that I can help Germans
and French work together.
This is also part of my work.
That goes without saying.
My experience is that if France
and Germany collaborate.
But with the Commission, as well,
and sometimes with other Member States…
If you build something together
from the start, it has much more impact.
In closing, a difficult question.
Who do you support in football?
The French or the German National Team?
In 2018, it was definitely Les Bleus.
We have some pictures
that we can show you now.
These are my sons.
That was a really great year.
I must say, these days I am lucky.
I usually have at least two teams
in every tournament.
So... I almost can't lose.
We have another picture.
This is you with Sebastian Kurz.
Oh yes, that's a great picture.
I was still pretty fit then.
That was a little over two years ago.
It was a Balkan summit.
Organized by Austria.
And there was a game
between the EU and Future EU.
I think Sebastian Kurz
was Foreign Minister then.
And I was the director for the Balkans
in the Commission at the time.
And I played
with the Balkan colleagues.
It was a friendly match.
It took place
in the Rapid Wien stadium.
It was very professional.
The referee was Johannes Hahn,
the Commissioner,
and Future EU won 4-2.
Thank you, Jean-Éric,
for being with us today
and for answering our questions.
Thank you so much for watching.
Now you can comment, watch again,
share with your friends.
And we still have a little game
to play with Nao.
You can watch that video here.
And see you soon
for a new episode of EU People.